YORK CITY.
THANK YOU.
MEANWHILE, THE U.S. MILITARY
GETTING CALLED UPON NOW DURING
THIS PANDEMIC CRISIS TO HELP THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, A GROUP YOU
MIGHT NOT BE THINKING ABOUT,
THOUGH, WHO ARE STANDING BY AND
READY TO HELP ARE THE NATION’S
VETERANS.
AND OUR NEXT GROUP -- OUR NEXT
GUEST, EXCUSE ME, WORKS FOR A
GROUP WHO WANTS TO MAKE SURE THE
CALL IS HEARD.
HE’S THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALL OF DUTY ENDOWMENT, DAN
GOLDENBERG, ALSO A RETIRED U.S.
NAVAL CAPTAIN, RESERVE NAVAL
CAPTAIN, HE HAS MORE THAN 27
YEARS OF MILITARY SERVICE UNDER
HIS BELT.
DAN, I WANT TO ASK YOU FIRST,
YOU SAY THAT OUR NATION’S
VETERANS ARE UNIQUELY QUALIFIED
TO HELP DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
TELL US ABOUT WHAT THEY CAN DO.
>> HI, GILLIAN.
THANKS.
WELL, YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
PRESIDENT’S ACTIONS WITH THE
MERCY AND THE COMFORT AND
CALLING UPON THE INACTIVE
RESERVE THAT THE KINDS OF SKILLS
THAT WE NEED RIGHT NOW DURING
THIS TIME OF CRISIS ARE IN --
WITHIN THE MILITARY, BE IT
COMMUNICATIONS, SUPPLY CHAIN, OF
COURSE MEDICAL.
THESE ARE FOLKS WHO CAN REPLY TO
A CRISIS, MAKE ORDER OUT OF
CHAOS.
THESE ARE THE KIND OF SKILLS
THAT OUR COUNTRY NEEDS RIGHT
NOW.
COMPANIES CAN’T OBVIOUSLY HIRE
THE MILITARY BUT THEY CERTAINLY
CAN HIRE VETERANS WHO HAVE THESE
SKILLS AT THIS TIME TO HELP WITH
THE NEEDS THAT WE FACE AS A
NATION RIG NOW.
>> SO WE HAVE THESE NATIONWIDE
HOT SPOTS NOW, WE HAVE THE
PROBLEMS, THE CONSEQUENCES
BROUGHTBYTHE PANDEMIC AND WE HAV
GROUP OF MAYBE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF AMERICAN VETERANS WHO ARE
ABLE-BODIED, LOOKING FOR WORK,
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE SOME OF THE
FOLKS ARE IN THE RIGHT PLACE AT
THE RIGHT TIME?
>> FIRST OF ALL, A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WE WERE
LOOKING AT IN EMPLOYMENT WAS
UNDER EMPLOYMENT, PEOPLE WORKING
BELOW THEIR SKILL SETS, MAKING
LESS MONEY BECAUSE OF THAT AND
THAT HIT VETS ESPECIALLY HARD.
NOW, JUST IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS
AS WE SURVEYED OUR GRANTEES WHO
LAST YEAR PLACED 11,000 VETERANS
IN JOBS, THEY’VE SEEN 59%
INCREASE IN DEMAND FOR VETERANS
ASKING FOR HELP.
>> WOW.
>> IT’S ALL ABOUT -- IT’S JUST
INCREDIBLE AND IT’S GOING TO GET
WORSE BEFORE IT GETS BETTER.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, THOSE VETERANS
OUT THERE THAT HAVE THESE SKILLS
THAT ARE NEEDED RIGHT NOW, YOU
KNOW, THIS CRISIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CUT THE RED TAPE
THAT’S PREVENTED CORPSMEN AND
MEDICS AND MILITARY TRUCK
DRIVERS, SOME OF THE MOST
UNEMPLOYED VETERANS, FROM
GETTING JOBS.
WE NEED TO CUT THAT RED TAPE.
IF YOU CAN PATCH SOMEONE
TOGETHER WHO IS BADLY INJURED IN
AFGHANISTAN, YOU SHOULDN’T HAVE
TO START OVER, RECERTIFYING TO
RIDE IN THE BACK OF AN
AMBULANCE.
WE NEED TO CUT THE RED TAPE AND
PUT THESE FOLKS TO WORK AND
WE’RE WELL POSITIONED AT THE
CALL OF DUTY ENDOWMENT TO HELP
WITH THAT.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE A NO-BRAINER
WHEN YOU LAY IT OUT THAT WAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER YESTERDAY WHERE
HE’S ESSENTIALLY AUTHORIZING THE
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT TO BRING BACK
FORMER TROOPS AND SOME NATIONAL
GUARDS FOLKS TO TRY AND HELP
EASE THE BURDEN THAT THE COUNTRY
IS UNDERGOING RIGHT NOW.
DOES THAT KIND OF GET US SOME OF
THE WAY THERE?
>> WELL, LOOK, IT’S JUST EMBLEM
ATTIC OF THE INCREDIBLE SKILL
SETS AND RESOURCES THE MILITARY
BRINGS TO BEAR.
I THINK IT’S SMART OBVIOUS
LIBRARYING THE COMFORT TO NEW
YORK AND THE MERCY TO LA, THAT
BRINGS THE SKILLS RIGHT THERE
BUT FOR EMPLOYERS WHO ARE --
WHILE MANY FOLKS ARE CUTTING
BACK HOURS AND LAYING OFF, MANY
OTHER INDUSTRIES NEED HELP.
OBVIOUSLY SUPPLY CHAIN
ESPECIALLY, MEDICAL, TO BE ABLE
TO CONNECT WITH THESE RESOURCES
IN THE VETERAN COMMUNITY IS
REALLY HELPFUL.
IT’S VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
INACTIVE RESERVES THAT THEY’RE
BEING USED CAREFULLY THAT WE’RE
NOT ROBBING PETER TO PAY PAUL,
FOLKS WHO ARE DOING IMPORTANT,
FOR INSTANCE, MEDICAL JOBS RIGHT
NOW AREN’T TAKEN AWAY FROM THOSE
TO SHIFT TO DIFFERENT AREAS WHEN
THEY’RE ALREADY DOING GOOD.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, THERE’S LOTS
OF VETERANS OUT HERE RIGHT NOW
AND WE CAN HELP THEM IF FOLKS GO
TO CALLOFDUTYENDODO
ENDOWMENT.ORG/HIGHER HONOR.
VETERANS WITH GREAT SKILL SETS
AND EMPLOYERS NEED THEM RIGHT
NOW.
>> QUICK FINAL QUESTION FOR
YOU, DAN.
WHAT DO YOU HEAR ABOUT THESE TWO
SHIPS THAT ARE MAKING THEIR WAY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, ONE ABOUT TO
HEAD OUT FROM NORFOLK, VIRGINIA
TO NEW YORK CITY, FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE SERVED ON
THEM OR BEEN ON-BOARD, CAN YOU
TELL US ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT
THEY’RE LIKE?
>> WELL, THEY’RE JUST INCREDIBLY
CAPABLE.
THEY’RE USNS SHIPS SO YOU HAVE
CIVILIAN GOVERNMENT GS CREWS WHO
RUN THEM AND YOU’VE GOT A
MILITARY CREW IN TERMS OF THE
MEDICAL SUPPORT STAFF AND
THEY’RE INCREDIBLE, 1,000 BEDS
ON EACH ONE OF THEM, INCREDIBLY
CAPABLE WITH OPERATING ROOM AND
ISOLATION FACILITIES, THEY’RE
READY TO GO.
OBVIOUSLY, THEIR PURPOSE IS TO
TAKE THE LOAD OFF THE
NONINFECTED PATIENTS SO THAT THE
HOSPITALS ON LAND CAN HAVE MORE
CAPACITY TO HELP THOSE IN
GREATEST NEED WITH COVID-19.
SO THESE CREWS ARE GOING TO DO
JUST AN ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC
JOB.
>> WELL, DAN GOLDENBERG OF THE
CALL OF DUTY ENDOWMENT, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TODAY.
THANKS FOR YOUR SERVICE.
FOR FOLKS AT HOME WHO ARE
WATCHING, IF YOU’RE AN EMPLOYER,
INTERESTED IN HIRING A VETERAN,
IF YOU HAVE A FRIEND OR NEIGHBOR
WHO IS A VETERAN LOOKING FOR
WORK, GO TO THE